Hey youtubers, what’s up.
This is going to be a breakdown of the new
trailer.
As you can see very Rogue centric.
The footage is only from the next couple of
episodes.
There’s info on all these episodes, just
to provide some better context I’ll do this
in order of each episode.
So I’ll be talking about characters we do
not see in the trailer too.
There’s a ton of new comic book people that
we’ll be seeing.
This trailer only shows Pied Piper, Heatwave,
Captain Cold which everyone already knows
about and this girl is probably Peek-A-Boo.
Starting with Episode 10 Revenge of the Rogues.
That’s what this footage is from.
Captain Cold and Heatwave team up.
The title is a play on Geoff John’s Rogues’
Revenge storyline from Final Crisis.
I’ll be interested to see if the episode
has anything to do with the comic story.
It involves the Bart Allen Flash, the Hunter
Zolomon Zoom and some Rogues we haven’t
seen on screen yet.
In addition to Heatwave and Captain Cold we’ll
see Osgood and Rachel Rathaway, In the comics,
they’re the parents of Hartley Rathaway,
who becomes the Pied Piper.
They’re a wealthy family that spends their
fortune trying to cure their son’s deafness.
He was born deaf, but on the show Pied Piper
is going to be more like Blackout from Episode
7, he’ll be another Star Labs employee that
was given powers in the blast.
I’ve already done a video for Heatwave so
if you want to learn more about him I’ll
add a link in the description.
Actually, a lot of these characters I’ve
done bonus videos for so just in general,
check the description for bonus links.
Episode 10 is mostly about introducing the
Heatwave character.
On that same coin, Jason Rusch is debuting.
I don’t know if it’s in a flashback or
in present day.
The way the producers explained it, is that
he was part of Project Firestorm with Professor
Martin Stein and Ronnie Raymond.
So they’ll probably end up using him to
develop the Firestorm plotline.
Episode 11 is called The Sound and the Fury.
This is part 1 of a two part Pied Piper story.
His character will also be in the next episode
after this.
Fun Fact, he’s actually the boyfriend of
Captain Singh.
Barry’s boss.
I’ll be interested to see how he reacts
to learning his boyfriend turns into a super
powered criminal.
Episode 12 is more Pied Piper and Martin Stein.
I don’t know if it will be flashback martin
stein or present day.
But Robbie Amell isn’t on the cast list.
We also meet this girl, I think this is Peek-A-Boo
from the comics.
She has powers of teleportation.
She’s not listed on the IMDB page but in
the comics, her character has a boyfriend
named Clay Parker who’s stuck in Iron Heights
Prison.
And he uses her to commit crimes but she’s
not an evil character.
Drum Roll please, because Linda Park is also
supposed to be in the episode.
In the comics, she becomes the wife of the
Wally West Flash.
She’s a reporter and Candice Patton’s
Iris West character is going to be working
as a reporter.
So we’ll probably meet Linda Park at the
place Iris works for.
They haven’t made any definitive statements
about Wally West other than they will do him
on the show.
Introducing Linda Park this early is just
them laying groundwork for that.
I know everyone is wondering how they’ll
explain Wally West because of the changes
they’ve made to the West family from the
comics.
I think the best options are to make Wally
Iris’ Cousin from out of town.
That way he wouldn’t have to be on the show
all the time.
Otherwise every episode people would keep
asking why Wally isn’t around.
That’s like Season 2 stuff, maybe even Season
3.
I don’t think they’re ready to start introducing
more people with Flash powers, they’ve already
got 3 including the Reverse Flashes.
That’s pretty much it for this trailer.
I think based on these characters there isn’t
any footage beyond episode 12.
So here’s my question for you guys.
If they’re doing Linda Park, do you want
to see Carol Ferris at some point.
I don’t think DC will let them do Green
Lantern, because they’re doing a new Green
Lantern/Flash movie in a couple years.
But they could do Carol Ferris.
There’s also an Arrow trailer just like
this with footage for the next couple of episodes
so I’m going to do the same thing for that
next.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Agent Carter had a really strong start but
Flash and Arrow are still the most fun comic
book shows on tv right now.
I won’t say best because I always change
my mind every week.
But they’re definitely the one’s I feel
the most connected to.
Right now click here to learn about some of
the other Rogues The Flash is doing this year
and click here to learn all about The Reverse
Flash in the comics.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!